st. Petersburg at its most majestic
grand historic Capitol the Romanovs ours
at its more mundane infamous modern hub
of Russian trolls hiving away in the
city's Grey office blocks and business
centers 55 savage Keener Street is where
the notorious internet research agency
was based the floors they vacated
available for rent for more than a year
now Batali Bespalov worked here in 2014
on the Ukraine section and was one of
the first to expose the trolling
operation for what it was reporting and
absolutely no chimney mania new clearing
at the Cattleman's portable lab I need
pitama so community essence okay Yahoo
sweet sweet porous lead on young Michael
Emily stuff and he's pulled the release
post bubbly eyes now Assad the internet
research agency is one of a number of
disinformation outlets run according to
US Special Counsel robert muller by
yevgeniy pre gordon a man whose shadowy
business empire stretches from
restaurants to media to mercenaries
[Applause]
Rush's fan News Agency is reported to be
part of it and it's where Elena who sign
of a works the only Russian indicted for
trying to interfere in the u.s. midterm
elections we met with suspicions and our
requests for an interview don't get far
this woman tells me that she's one of
the editors for special information
projects like the midterms the u.s.
midterm elections but I don't get an
answer to that fan released a statement
from hassanover shortly after the news
of her indictment
kakuzu / - yeah prosperous escape you
got a liberal American some president
you score above average in de patata of
heroism will ania Patricia na we tried
to track down where she lived but no
answer she's registered to that address
which does not look like the kind of
property that the woman running the
finances for a fake news media empire
owns we also know that she owns property
in that address there but the
receptionist said that she has moved out
and that she told him that if anyone
came asking not to pass on her details
luckily they passed on ours for sign of
her calls she tells my producer she'll
think about an interview that she too
has more questions than answers but when
we tried her again a bit of dispersed
Ito and the line went dead in the grand
scheme of things who sign of her is
small-fry an ordinary Russian doing
ordinary things for what the US says is
an extraordinary mission hiding in plain
sight far removed from the arm of US
Justice Diana Magnay Sky News some
Petersburg